what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation thank you so much for clicking on this
video what are we gonna watch today Michael
tesler MJ tesler the michaelorian the Michael
Oher the midichlorians episode 5 of what season
John season three including everyone in this
intro because I am a generous Lord anyway
guys you know what to do leave a like that's
the proper way to go about business I gotta
grab grogu before we film this episode reaction
also subscribe and click the notification
Bell at some point and it's midnight right
now we gotta shoot bad batch I guess I got
into that as well there's a superior Star
Wars series to keep a lookout for that because
you know come hopefully within the next 24
to 48 hours also um wanted to give a mention
it was supposed to arrive today but we had
just finished the design over the weekend
at shopzeroedition.com that's for all of our
real rejects merch is located we have launched
a new shirt that you can now purchase and
I'm telling you it's one of greggy's favorites
or should I say daddy's favorite look at it
we got here look at that Joel daddy Pedro
holding up baby grogu and I love the text
says Child Protection Services I think it's
hilarious you get it guys because Joe protects
you guys get it I don't know explain it you're
smart but yeah one of the best ways to support
the channel is by getting these awesome designs
we got plenty of stuff over there and full
interaction watch songs of our patreon page
let's get this show on the road
[Music]
I'm here for my hot springs where's the real
spur we're going to be moving a lot of cargo
in and out of here grief cargo hold on a second
got a bad feeling about this
Pirates we did Jack you get the citizens to
safety I'll handle this Engineers thank you
to be continued Engineers I do not know your
names oh that's an opposing hologram all I
see before me is a Pampered nobleman dressed
for the pump of his wedding Feast alliteration
gunning down my Helmsman In Cold Blood when
he let down his guard on your planet he shot
first nice reference hail me again unless
it's to surrender oh no oh boy what you were
supposed to be Navarro's Savior and now he
will be its Reckoning oh Lordy do are they
about to destroy Navarro yep yeah wow that
is an aerial bombardment
those extras are having the time of their
life right now I will lead you to the launch
site I won't abandon my city we have to get
the people to safety he's like Boba Fett for
motivation
getting some uh final season of Game of Thrones
Vibes right now sure [Music]
wow that's imposing oh pirate up
accordion in there too
yes
Dope music this is epic I want to go to a
Star Wars Rave now
blow the situation is dire I'm afraid that
our planet will fall shark will turn this
into a pirate base a Pirate Bay
too bad you're asking you don't make me look
like an idiot I really thought Navarro was
gonna make it they haven't returned a dispatch
in weeks they're swamped they'll never get
an answer in time it can't be from Rebels
I can't ignore me face to face I love your
attitude I think it is you are right Michael
it is Zeb Steve Blum and everything you're
gonna need it oh he looks great it's tying
in no no no do not put any more stuff no [__]
Tim Meadows you never once paid for Droids
early in John that was great
you once offered that I might reach out to
you I'm gonna play this whole thing again
I get the gist it does sound concerning oh
no have you ever heard of Navarro I have some
time there in fact I'm not a member Planet
oh it's not good
Navarro has reported accounts of Storm Troopers
in the streets and Tie fighters openly flying
above pirate king is attempting the same thing
these events can all be connected these are
serialized because I'm hearing moth Gideon
never made it to trial perhaps the leaders
of Navarro need to understand why becoming
a republic signatory is valuable by letting
them suffer she is great you and your sword
didn't see the light you were captured no
I was liberated
[Music] all these events it's not coincidence
and by the time it becomes big enough for
you to act it'll be too late this guy's like
the head writer of the room I need to lay
this out for the audience the show is about
something guys
wow
this escalated quickly
there's a concerning lack of survivors
ah visiting the mandalorians he knows where
they're located that's what I'm confused about
unless he has a uh tracker or something Oh
Captain Carson Tava how did you manage to
find us someone I served with in the Rebellion
is amongst your ranks uh-oh awkward
thanks R5 [Music] they're about to blow Navarro
to Hell the new Republic has to know that
the Empire is growing again and you think
the pirate king has something to do with it
interesting but something doesn't smell right
look it's not your fight I just came to tell
you your friend is in danger then a Monster
eats him and that's the whole episode just
getting it back so what are you thinking he's
right I gotta help the guy yeah the enemy
that decimated this very covert were Imperials
not grief cargas bounty hunters it's true
grief karga is now a high magistrate and has
offered me attractive land Perhaps it is time
for us to live in the light once again on
a planet where we are welcome on a commune
and our children can feel what it is to play
in the sunlight with their helmets on and
roasting their heads farmallorians
I have the speaking Hammer now I fought against
grief cargo I saw many Die to Save the life
of this one tiny foundling oh he feels bad
and now we are asked to sacrifice yet again
yeah the question we should be asking ourselves
is why why should we lay our lives down yet
again he told he he's he's he kind of he said
it you gotta listen because we are mandalorians
he risked his life to save my son did not
give up on my child's life even when even
when the rest of us did the speech took a
turn dang this is the way this is the word
this is the way they're just getting along
this is great we are Zion if everyone acts
as they should we can use the element of surprise
and defeat an enemy that outnumbers us nice
shot okay this is gonna be amazing Navarro
is an independent planet and no longer under
Remnant Imperial or New Republic protection
rise of the mandalorians you lived there once
hiding in the sewers but now you can be heroes
just for one day ninety percent of them die
you can be martyrs that's okay they repopulate
it really fast they do
oh poor Droid
this feels like Pirates of the Caribbean in
Disneyland yeah yeah I was thinking this is
Disneyland gotta be someone chasing somebody
with a rolling pin yeah that's exactly it
it's literally exactly that
[Music] oh
Captain there's a Starfighter [Music]
imagine so the same race as the quail character
they did work for the Empire historically
speaking all of you to return Why is drugu
there
and they got you outnumbered ten to one I
like those odds [Music]
that's a cool looking ship though yeah right
[Music] of course here's on me the coast is
clear love the Hammerhead design to it and
the approaching drop point and the daunting
looking paint job prepare to drop I've been
waiting for this trailer moment yes baby baby
go
nice boom look I have like a scimitar area
clear team two you with us I want this video
game and I want it now dude open world Mando
video game
[Music]
you're starting to run
do a barrel roll ah baby camera class fighter
transport
love this Power Rangers villain
we won't get away this time
the star bite is a decoy there's a secondary
attack looks like you'll get away this time
[Music] come on
thanks salacious krem's cousin
oh great shot wow
[Laughter] [Music]
oh my god oh nice Get Wrecked
full on Arnold or T2 right there yeah minigun
son
oh God that gotta hurt
damn that one gun
love this pirate Squadron this is dope pirates
of the outer rim [Music] love you he's below
you he's everywhere
damn
[Music]
oh
my god wow all clear Advanced dude
foreign
this is everything I've ever dreamed of [Music]
[Music]
awesome damn it's time to part ways
we're down to our last engine we have to retreat
[Music]
Focus fire on their last engine
and send the ship crashing into town oh man
I'll make for a Cool Base wow POV
epic downfall wow
Now That's What I Call television all right
little Babu mandalorians I know that we have
been on opposite sides in the past that is
behind us cool hereby seed all Land from the
Western lava Flats to pull a canyon to the
Fine people of Mandalore amazing you do now
have a home welcome Tesla just shoots him
[Applause]
the armor
oh my God it's the armor gonna seduce her
remove your helmet what she
sure remove your helmet
you've broken the Creed leave our people have
strayed from the way we must walk the way
together oh mandalorians what are you getting
at here the old night owls I understand bringing
them on board I was taught the mrsor existed
only in Legends oh it is a sign that the next
age is upon us
Mandalore must all come together right now
under walked Both Worlds you were the one
who can unite us
[Music] oh [__] she gonna make uh Beau
challenged in for the dark saber that feels
like a thing that would need to happen Boca
Don Crees is going off to bring other mandalorians
in Exile to us but she shows her face yes
she does the town walks Both Worlds she can
bring all tribes together
good Kitty sack off is just too cool looking
to not have her face peace in it is time to
retake Mandalore
thank you that's awesome damn [Music]
don't don't mark my guy
that is an imperial shuttle [Music]
nope almost left
a one
oh no
that's some Ridley Scott [__] here yeah
let's do a little dead space right now let's
go any reports in the area
a record of a missing craft in the region
the details are classified oh boy R7 launch
probe
what is suspenseful
ah cool Pro that's what she said I'm sending
her transponder signal
oh my goodness no no I don't like it it's
a new Republic prison transport
I'll be damned flight times match the ship
transporting moth Gideon what do you know
they don't appear to be any survivors something
must remain and moth Gideon's body is missing
there appears to be something embedded in
the cabin wall getting close on that
[Music] um the fragment of best car alloy
taken by mandalorians oh [__] what
[Music] whoa who else do we know out there
with some best guard to spare well the mandalorians
who were not with Bo Katan anymore sure could
be them they're also historically speaking
uh the Imperial super Commandos were expandalorians
I don't think it's gonna go that path what
was that I don't think it's going to go that
way you know a Boy Can Dream a Boy Can Dream
all right let's chit chat about a gang you
are right Michael it is Zeb my man Steve Blum
and everything uh what in extraordinary live
action appearance of one of my favorite animated
Star Wars characters that's crazy yeah uh
I mean I was the timeline made a sense what
does that imply though because he's not with
the other rest of the game I mean well Sabine
left off yeah well I know he'll be is he is
he confirmed to be innatoka no no so last
we left off in the epilogue of rebels Phoenix
Squadron had gone their separate ways uh Zeb
uh his Homeworld was destroyed by The Imperials
and one of the big arcs uh was them finding
a new uh hyperspace Lane uh that led to a
new plan it where they were able to bring
this all so Vaguely Familiar I know it's similar
correct I know it's in there uh but it is
I know yeah I binged like so quick admittedly
I watched Rebels like four or five times just
give you an idea of my memory just to give
everyone a Breaking Bad I praise is my favorite
show of all time yeah I'm watching it for
the third time with my wife because she's
never seen it and ninety percent of the time
I'm like I don't remember any of this that's
my favorite show like a lot to cook they jam-packed
a lot that's what my main thing is yeah but
you know last we saw him uh he was taking
a former ISB officer uh and showing him the
home world and the ISB officer was the one
that flipped uh was the double agent it was
just one of my favorite Arts uh in in Rebels
but no I mean it makes sense that that uh
Zed would be part of the new Republic uh and
I just I thought the live action was just
really really well done I always was worried
about how a lasat would translate on a live
action screen and uh very pricey CG effect
yeah that's probably the number one reason
we won't see Zeb in Ahsoka uh but he weirdly
looked taller than I remember him in the show
I mean it I know he's taller than everyone
else but he looked even taller then I was
like you remember uh Fallen order um the Jedi
Master uh of Cal yes yeah same same species
so it's cool we've now officially seen lasates
it's just the first live action yeah action
animation uh and in a video game so I'm sure
I'm sure everyone else is caught that it is
Zeb right away too but like I just thought
it was one of the creatures well it was for
a minute I was like is it just a lassade and
then once you hear the the voice I mean uh
Steve Blum just an amazing voice actor all
over the place um it was just I don't know
moments like that uh where you know for for
those of us that watched Rebels uh it's just
a really nice payoff and a little homage um
this is a blast and a half in this episode
had a like a substantial amount of I feel
like most of the things that are fun that
you want but also most of the things that
by episode five of eight you should feel like
there's a direction kind of tying all of them
together um so yeah I thought this was it's
been an interesting season overall I'm curious
to see how they they stick The Landing but
I appreciated the immediacy of this as well
as just the sort of strange and uncomfortable
tones that peppered the sort of ending of
both the situation with the mandalorians intervening
on the Pirates and Boca tan and the armor
are having this whole sort of you know maybe
you should take up the torch exchange and
then you're trying to lift the camera trying
to force choke me into we have an audio version
on our like Spotify and stuff but you guys
can't see what I'm doing yeah yeah yeah my
goal is just to throw John off his face and
you have everyone on the audio side have no
idea what's happening why John's trailing
uh but yeah so many uh disparate threads from
both across this season as well as across
just the whole show kind of coming into the
light and yeah you have your sort of micro
situation with grief karga the mandalorians
finding hope for the future I thought was
really kind of just a nice cathartic thing
and I like the way that they really kind of
wound you up and then gave a nice subversion
with Paz visla actually being like no we should
absolutely take this cause up I thought that
was really kind of rewarding after you know
kind of exactly what you expect to happen
having happened before uh in just him being
you know sort of naturally in opposition um
that's true it's an interesting Tim Meadows
appearance which it worked perfect it was
the perfect character for that exact kind
of role he's the red yeah I'm very fascinated
because I've heard at least some some vague
criticisms of the show at this point being
sort of like okay we don't really know what
the perspective is as we're looking out at
the new Republic at the you know remnants
of the Empire even the Persistence of these
mandalorians and the other you know kind of
disparate groups across the Galaxy other than
like the basics of just like ah we want to
have our society and live in peace and whatever
so I'm curious to see because it seems like
in casting uh Tim Meadows here as this new
Republic officer it seems like so many of
the new Republic people are a bit dweebie
or sad sackish or just ineffectual seeming
and then you've got this guy like blue who's
sort of caught in the middle of it who's like
that beat cop who just wants to actually make
a difference and getting caught up such a
great way to put it yeah and so like I'm I'm
curious to see that theme like be substantially
committed to but like I can feel the sort
of like seeds of it there yeah well I mean
you're describing the birth of the resistance
uh which is something that like when the sequel
films came out I did not jive with I was like
this just seems a little why are they just
kind of thrown in the towel on the new Republic
you know why did Leia feel the need to create
this like paramilitary organization uh and
the reason is because the new Republic is
absolute garbage uh from from what we've seen
and and so I think we're beginning to see
the uh people historically speaking after
a war they kind of lose the appetite for fighting
and uh I think people are just kind of content
for a little bit of calm you know when in
reality uh when you're dealing with evil space
fascists uh you gotta always be vigilant so
yeah no it this was such a great episode in
that I think Navarro as we all talked about
in the beginning of the Season it was really
wonderful to watch the transformation of this
planet uh and and now for the mandalorians
to really kind of plant their flag and have
a new home base uh you know the the mandalorians
are much more than just Mandalore as it's
kind of been alluded to you know it was at
one point very much an Empire and of itself
you know with with lots of different systems
and lots of different planets and uh I kind
of love the implication that maybe this is
the beginning of that uh and you know I think
they've really subverted expectation uh particularly
between the armorer and bow which I think
all of us really felt strongly they were not
gonna get along um but I feel like they're
you know little finger and verus kind of using
each other in a in a poetic way to to achieve
a means to an end um but like Boca town is
a really controversial like I love her um
but might not be the one to actually make
this happen um and I'm beginning to think
that they are going to die a heroic death
that will lead to the return of the mandalorians
truly um but I do not see a world in which
they are actually capable of leading the mandalorians
um so yeah Greg what did you think
[Laughter]
yeah no I mean I agree with everyone's sentiments
here I I do I do like how they handled it
I there's something about the scenes though
though with the armor and Boca tan that they
I feel like they purposely play up a little
even now it's like it's there's something
leading in that feels like a dark presence
is looming amongst that like in the atmosphere
between their conversations uh until she like
goes out there to talk and it sucks about
like hey let's accept the fact that we got
kind of different denominations and it's just
about everyone coming together and it's not
about which which uh religion is the proper
way to go about it you know we're all Christians
guys well I was gonna I was gonna it does
give a lot of those Crusade type Vibes where
it's like all right Orthodox and Catholics
we're just gonna remember that the Muslims
are in Jerusalem and well what happens though
when you're dealing with very passionate people
though people like Vizsla whoever Bo Katan
decides to bring by is you I I guess I'm wondering
if Star Wars is gonna chicken out and not
actually do something interesting with different
ideologies and like like if Isla was a little
bit surprised to see her helmet was off but
is that going to create a ripple effect of
distrust uh their Mantra being so much of
being this is the way with this being the
a specific way to live and [__] what didn't
just had to go through just to get back in
how can they accept the fact that there's
other man and will the show do that or are
they going to be like no we're just hopeful
and nice and we're gonna be coming together
yeah well I I think it's it's this idea of
conversion where they're welcome to come into
the fold also bathe in the Living Waters of
the minds of Mandalore and then at that point
be able to walk the way but in order to get
them there you've got to get them there and
I think there is a surprising amount of wisdom
coming from a cult leader uh in the form of
the armorer uh in in in trying to bring in
the night owls and any other kind of mandalorians
um you know I just I agree with you the the
tone it always feels so Sinister and dark
uh and it feels like the mandalorians are
just like doomed to repeat their history over
and over and over again and you know the what
kind of preceded all of this was you know
book 10 sister uh who was part of like the
peace loving mandalorians who tried to break
that cycle and it worked out so well for them
um and so yeah I I know you're talking about
Duchess Satine yeah Obi-Wan the pacifist one
of the mandalorians and it created a whole
problem for everyone yeah sure did God got
killed I remember that not Zeb the only thing
that matters well it's uh I mean Obi-Wan Kenobi
is the father of the confusing nephew of bog
Katan and the uh The Duchess sure uh damn
a lot of the directors were [__] in this
episode I want one episode where only the
director
felony family in this episode Where's the
where's Dallas hours that was wild I just
noticed that right now yeah um well yeah I
mean but as an episode as a whole I thought
while it was very entertaining the the pirate
there is something about when you're translating
live like I don't have the Pirates ever been
in Clone Wars Rebels I don't recall not those
particularly nothing is like Vain and all
that piracy is a concept exists with these
guys as much as they were like blowing up
Navarro and stuff the show It's the episode
itself as big and scopic as beautiful as a
lot of these shots were I like more of the
context of where it all led us to I felt more
um tension and suspense and stakes in like
the last minute of this episode and the in
the dread in the dread space moment then anything
dealing with the Pirates agreed and that's
something that I feel like this ought to have
had it does and that's why I'm kind of hoping
that okay we're five episodes in yeah and
they tease something that feels off about
these conversations like like one of them's
manipulating the it just seems that way I
don't know if we're reading into it but they
play some dark ass music and they they talk
slow to each other if it's a Donut's a waste
yeah that's an absolute if it's a fake out
it would be a bit of a drink no yeah instead
of just like yeah we all get along hooray
I think they're building to something that
is going to be a little Sinister and is it
just going to be something as simple as you
know the Empire is lurking in the shadows
again they're on the rise you got someone
in the new Republic who they think is reformed
or liberated but she's really helping to you
know string things up yeah yeah we have that
going on we got MAF has been broken out who
else might be siding with the dark side right
as the first order blah blah blah and then
what mandalorians they fight alongside them
and where were they in the sequel Trilogy
do they all die by the end like is that where
we're going with this is that they all band
together because I like it when it's more
intimate and personal with them and I think
that um that was one thing like this episode
was really fun uh but it did lack a certain
substance of of of emotional weight rather
than just like I like the context a lot I
think that's been a challenge that they've
had since bringing all the mandalorians together
uh it's almost like these victory feel a little
bit too inevitable um and because of that
the stakes are never really as high as they
should be I mean that that last you know two
minutes of the episode uh I think a lot of
that tension is because it captures a lot
of the tone of something like Andor um where
it it's a I I mean that's like like it's one
of the things that I love about the Mandalorian
it's one of the things that I hate about the
Mandalorian is that it there's this constant
desire to emulate like the Fantastical craziness
of of something like the Clone Wars yeah um
but it doesn't always translate to live action
and and sometimes those those darker more
grounded live-action moments just feel a lot
heavier and and like the stakes are there
yeah this season is so far felt like it's
it's bigger and way more action like it's
been feeling that way like it's bigger and
way more action yet it hasn't felt as uh within
its action scenes as truly emotionally gripping
is even in the way of like when the socatanos
uh return episode uh the one that like really
felt like it was riffing on like uh Seven
Samurai in a way even though I don't know
these people and everything there's a certain
mood about it where like this is captivating
and here you're just like this is big cool
yeah you know yeah and there's a quality too
where like during this episode I did find
myself getting distracted going like okay
while you guys are sitting around while while
you're flying across the Galaxy to get approval
for this backup and while you mandalorians
are arguing about whether or not to go to
Navarro in the first place these Pirates can
decimate anything that matters kind of immediately
and when they get there you have this like
little pocket of all them and they kind of
get out of town and you get this like yeah
they've destroyed stuff but you don't feel
the true harsh like they're they're just massacring
innocent people and you don't really have
that flavor actually present in the episode
and so well that's why I was liking it to
the Ahsoka episode sure because that's the
first time you check in with them and it just
seems like a a such a bleak miserable situation
yeah yeah this still feels real bright and
colorful no I mean we did I think we described
it best I mean it was like the Pirates of
the Caribbean sequence and like where it's
like weirdly kind of fun like like oh look
at this occupation uh and the salacious crumbs
getting shot I didn't get a true sense of
the suffrage yeah well and there's also a
thing too that yeah like a true sense of the
suffering and the and just the the sheer harshness
of like this is like you know they don't adhere
to any law but this is like a war crime of
of massive proportions essentially um but
also I think there is a certain thing that
to me it makes me curious because I think
there's a potential for the show to be at
odds with itself in the fact that when the
show was just about din jarin I feel like
you can have your Mandalorian cake a little
bit and eat it too in the sense that you have
all the Mystique but you don't necessarily
have to confront it as head-on as you do when
you have them all together and trying to like
reform their whole uh culture and Society
because the Mandalorian culture is one rot
on like violence and all sorts of conquest
and things that are like really dark and hard
to rectify in a way that's like a really easy
to root for protagonist situation ideal for
Disney plus yeah so I feel like even though
it is like fun and interesting to watch them
rebuild at the same time I'm like how much
is this show gonna have to kneecap itself
from the true potential of what's really interesting
about that without nerfing the mandalorians
or like creating this weird face turn that
doesn't quite jive with the rest of the Galaxy
I'm gonna make a weird comparison here uh
I feel like The Walking Dead had the same
exact issue uh in the early Seasons it was
really intimate and personal and then it it
wanted to evolve into a very different type
of show where all of a sudden there's like
settlements and factions and it's much bigger
and it never really knew how to make that
transition and I feel like this season I hope
is The Growing Pains of them figuring that
out and that they do figure it out by next
season because the stakes are much higher
than just DIN and grogu uh and and I think
that you know kudos to them for being brave
enough to try uh and I I think I'm gonna have
nothing but but faith in optimism uh in our
Lord and savior that's all no I still quite
like I I just think the first and this episode
were the ones that I I don't I like this more
than the first episode yeah um I do it's just
more like yeah this is this was fun with a
a very interesting last few minutes yeah with
the armor and stuff um but yeah there is a
lack of tension yeah the most tense when there
should be tension in a lot of even the scene
when you had um oh my God wait a minute I
have the castles right here what is his name
what's what's the Asian guys do oh he kept
saying it blue blue for sure there's something
with a c yeah it's uh uh boy Crimson Chris
Pine for something well anyway with that seem
a blue and Carson Carson Carson you're right
about that yeah Carson uh Carson and Tim Meadows
and the girl from the episode that was divisive
for people that I I love I second that I love
that was the most tense and most sort of intimately
perilous feeling I love that episode yeah
that one um but yeah I thought that um that
scene too was like ah this is kind of like
moving it's like the first episode let's move
a little quick let's move a little too quick
for me yeah it's those multiple povs and it's
that transition to that type of show that
is just uh I cannot imagine how that writer's
room like their formula you just had to throw
out but I think the second and third episode
were [__] fantastic I think the second
third episode were really fantastic they weren't
afraid to be intimate and the focused was
this the fourth fifth fifth what was the fourth
episode
[__] what happened last week finding out
who's safe grow goo oh yeah oh yeah
it was just a pure blast but yeah yeah I'm
getting back from yeah I think that's the
challenge really quick episode yeah I know
absolutely a lot in it yeah this is an interestingly
shaped and and tonally paced you think it
would be more focused and breathe better considering
how serialized it is I feel like there was
a shortage of Adderall in the writer's room
this season yeah it was a little Ryan Murphy
yeah but but you know what it's still so fun
true and uh you know that's what Star Wars
is at its core uh fun to the point where you're
angry about it
because you're not having the right kind of
fun that I'm having final final thoughts please
final five it's been 23 minutes yeah I was
this was a good talk uh the best scar Alloy
at the end uh I I feel like you might be onto
something with it being the the night owls
and and those kind of abandoned bow but part
of me also wonders like this guy occupied
Mandalore and had access to like bescar I
wonder if there is some cool stuff that we
haven't seen yet um true so you know and for
the rebels fans thrown out my last little
nerdy tidbit here but like I also wouldn't
be surprised if you know the the Gara saxon's
relatives uh who was the Imperial Mandalorian
uh there were Imperial mandalorians and I
don't want to write that off because I feel
like as you talked about the different sects
uh of the Mandalorian culture that would be
really neat to show that that was you know
part of what played a role in the downfall
of Mandalore so final ticks shows cone a bit
mcu-ish come on yeah Spaceballs in the beginning
no anyway guys thanks for being here uh what
did you think about the episode though please
leave your thoughts down below I'll respond
uh follow Michael check us on patreon get
that data shirt also listen to the patreon
Everett pixelmite Baker my dude listen up
there are so many people that would be the
the de facto you know person that we would
Heap the mantle of the reject Nation on who
walk both worlds and you I think are the most
uh you know resilient person to do that for
us because you here walk two identities you
have Everett Baker mild-mannered citizen of
the world you know just out here supporting
their favorite channels but within you have
pixel might who's who knows the potential
of what you could do with power based in pixels
of the foundations of the modern world man
we do everything on pixelated displays every
image you see is an amalgamation of smaller
bits and pieces and that is the power the
strength that exists within you so let it
free and thus he maintain your pledge to the
patreon because that's like the Living Water
that's how you keep your you know Creed status
in good standing and good faith with us but
other than that you know don't be an apostate
don't be an apostate and Chuck your prostate
because uh physical health is also a good
thing you know can confirm love you Everett
stay well and we'll catch you for an even
better more coherent shout out next month
love you buddy see you buddy